pense pour refermer ce chapitre cette
évidence qui était encore discutée il ya
quelques années mais qui s'imposent
aujourd'hui ces vagues de chaleur et
parfois de canicule s'inscrivent bien
dans un réchauffement général du climat
un réchauffement qui s'accélère les
scientifiques en sont maintenant
convaincus
agnès montrent un michael cariou la mer
du nord qui prend des airs de côte
d'azur d'ici un siècle
cela n'étonnera plus personne car les
scientifiques en sont maintenant sur wii
il y a bien réchauffé climatique d'ici
100 ans
il y aura dix fois plus de canicule
qu'aujourd'hui on sacoor de manière de
ballon de manière très consensuelle sur
le fait que la température augmentera
entre 2 et 6 degrés au cours du prochain
siècle quelques degrés de plus qui
devrait menacer la moitié des espèces en
france
les oiseaux migrateurs par exemple ils
descendent déjà moins au sud est restent
en france sous les eaux tandis que les
poissons de méditerranée se tropicalisé
ceux de la mer du nord remonte de plus
en plus près des pôles nos forêts vont
se métamorphoser
il y aura moins de hêtres et plus de
pain ou de chêne vert l'agriculture
devra s'adapter
on recherche déjà de nouvelles variétés
d'arbres fruitiers ou de blé moins
sensibles aux écarts de température mais
on redoute surtout le développement de
nouvelles maladies graves
avec l'arrêté d'insectes ou de virus
tropicaux
on sait qu'avec l'évolution attendue du
changement climatique il faut
s'orienter là dessus donc evola la
fièvre du nil des choses comme ça le
tourisme devra aussi évolué moins de
neige dans nos montagnes sur le glacier
et de nombreuses zones côtières
submergés sous la montée des eaux dans
100 ans la camargue par exemple
devraient avoir disparu